17.
this is
philly
episodes
no
yeah
um
oh
so
here
is
uh
how are you doing
i don't need them
it was really bad
louis or wavelength
probably
feel good
sheltering and things
you
is
stick right here
it's a tough time
hello
you have probably
okay
yes
counterfeit
is
foreign
my
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
accompanied by the vice president thank
you very much
thank you
so beautiful out here and thank you for
joining us as we announce a massive and
groundbreaking expansion in our testing
capability of the for the china virus
and as you know it's already setting
records records like
nobody's ever seen before last week we
crossed a historic milestone
when the united states conducted our 100
millionth
test far more than any other country
and not even close actually second seems
to be india
with 1.5 billion people and the numbers
would be
probably at least 50 million more tests
by us
we've conducted more tests than the
entire european union and
more than all of latin america combined
we're thrilled to be joined by vice
president mike pence secretary of health
and human services
alex azar secretary of education
betsy devos hi betsy administrator for
the centers for medicine and
medicaid services sema verma sema
and admiral jawah who's done such an
incredible job
thank you admiral we're also joined by
mississippi
governor tate greaves had a tremendous
victory we're so proud of you
and as well by abbott ceo robert ford
robert thank you very much great job
today i'm pleased to report that we're
announcing our plan to distribute 150
million habit rapid point of care tests
in the coming weeks very very soon
this will be more than double the number
of tests already performed
and here's our plan 50 million tests
will go to protect the most vulnerable
communities
which we've always promised to do
including 18 million for nursing homes
15 million for assisted living
facilities
10 million for home health and hospice
care hospice care agencies and nearly 1
million for
historically black colleges and
universities and also
tribal nation colleges 100 million rapid
point-of-care tests will be given to
states and territories to support
efforts to reopen their economies and
schools immediately and fast as they can
for example the support my
administration is providing
would allow every state to on a very
regular basis test
every teacher who needs it this
continues our critical effort to use
testing to protect high-risk communities
these new abbott rapid point-of-care
tests are easy to use and return results
within just minutes
you'll have a result at a maximum 15
minutes
machine no machine is required to
process them so
in the old days when we just started
this you remember we'd go out and
we'd have to find these massive
laboratories with tremendously expensive
equipment now we're
down to something that you'll see that
is really
from a different planet i would like to
ask admiral
gerard to come up and demonstrate how
these tests are performed he'll do this
very nicely i think
good luck hope you don't test positive
so thank you mr president uh as of today
the nation
has performed over 111 million tests for
the virus causing covid
on 13 separate days we have achieved
tests over 1 million per day
and our average test numbers are now
approximately 920
000 per day we are now at an inflection
point in testing
we now have available on average three
million tests per day
not counting pool testing which could
multiply that number
several fold nearly half of our current
tests
are rapid point of care all of the
actions of your administration including
aggressive use of multiple
titles of the dpa hundreds of millions
of dollars in
hhs and dod investments and regulatory
flexibility including
over 200 fda emergency use
authorizations
clia enforcement discretion and
application of the prep act
have led us to this inflection point
which brings us
why we're here today on august 27
after months of planning and only after
one day after the fda authorization
the trump administration awarded a
contract for 760 million dollars
to abbott for the delivery of 150
million
of these avid binax now rapid tests
the binax now detects the presence of
the covet antigen
it uses a specific nasal swab and that
oops
that swab comes with the test and it's
made by purity
and the reason why puritan swabs are
here is because the administration used
the dpa
and 120 million dollars in investment to
make these swabs able
for to use by avid it does not require
an
instrument to determine the result it's
15 it's in 15 minutes the result
testing may be performed by laboratories
with a clear certificate of waiver
this is not a home test but during the
health emergency
sema verma and cms permits laboratories
to extend their certificate
to operate in temporary sites like
schools or churches
are parking lots so though i we
anticipate that the test will generally
be performed by a trained individual and
a patient
i will demonstrate a self swab for you
to show you just exactly how easy the
test is performed
so literally it almost could not be
easier
it starts with six drops of liquid onto
this piece of paper
one two three four
five six
and then there's a nasal swab and again
this is uh
this is not the deep brain biopsy that
we talk about
this will generally done by a healthcare
provider but it can be done supervised
it's this easy
one two three four five one two
three four five into the test
twisted three times
the adhesive is pulled off and you wait
15 minutes
and that is the test it really could not
be easier than this
this is a very sophisticated little
piece of cardboard with lots of
antibodies and incredible technology
into that
we've already shipped 65 000 of these to
disaster operations in california oregon
texas and louisiana
and we have already shipped 2.1 million
tests
to 7 600 nursing homes over 900
000 tests to assisted living 300 000
tested the indian health service
and 339 000 tests to historically black
colleges and university
today we start the shipment of a hundred
million tests to governors
beginning with a total of 6.5 million
tests
this week to be shipped this week this
is an addition
to the continuing support to other
priorities like nursing homes
allocation to states and territories is
based strictly on their relative
population governors have the
flexibility to use these tests
as they deem fit but we strongly
encourage governors to utilize them in
settings
that are uniquely in need of rapid
low-tech point-of-care tests
like opening and keeping open our k-12
schools
supporting first responders
responding to outbreaks specifically in
certain demographics or locations
and screening of surveillance in
congregate settings mr president we just
completed a briefing to the governors
and their state health officials from
the sit room and we heard words like
game changer for their states thank you
mr president for your leadership and
support
of all our efforts to defeat this virus
very much
let me ask you uh governor reeves do you
uh do you agree
would you like to say something
thank you mr president for your
leadership
through this pandemic and through this
crisis
this is it was said by republicans and
democrats alike
earlier this is a game changer in our
state of mississippi our k-12 schools
have been
open for nine weeks our institutions of
higher learning have been open
for about the same but while we have
testing available now at least once a
week
in every county of our state what this
allocation is going to allow for us is
we will have
testing available for our k through 12
teachers every single day going forward
and the thing that we know is that kids
learn
and secretary devos knows this so well
kids learn so much better when they're
in the classroom
than when they're doing distance
learning or a hybrid
and while we have 75 to 80 percent of
our kids back in the classroom we want
to get 100 of our kids
back in the classroom it is also
incredibly important mr president your
decision to allocate
on the front end to the historically
black colleges and universities
means the world to mississippi our
larger institutions have the financial
resources
to provide testing but in mississippi
with jackson state university and alcorn
univer
alcorn state university and mississippi
valley state university three of our
eight institutions of higher learning
will get an allocation of these tests
and it's going to make a difference
and kids all across our state are going
to be better served because of it and i
want to personally thank you
on behalf of the residents of
mississippi for doing this mr president
thank you
thank you very much thank you ted great
job
in a short period of time my
administration has built the most
advanced testing system in the world
there's never been anything like this
when the pandemic struck there were zero
tests for the
china virus but we've marshaled all of
america's resources to achieve these
unparalleled capabilities we slashed red
tape and approved
emergency use authorizations for
243 type of tests that's how many tests
we have
i invoked the defense production act and
related authorities more than 100 times
and distributed
171 million dollars to expand testing
production
we've done nearly twice as much testing
per capita as france
italy and germany and over six times
more testing
per capita than south korea we've done
far more than any other country
usually times two three four five or six
we performed nearly 40 million more
tests in india and
by the end of next month we will have
over 100 million tests available in the
market
more than half will be point of care
tests those are the quick ones and
uh they're really the ones that have the
best impact
with the results in less than 15 minutes
we've also
prioritized resources for the votes most
vulnerable including nursing home
residents we delivered rapid testing
devices to nearly 14 000 certified
nursing homes
we opened over 1 000 community testing
sites in low-income communities nobody
could have done this we invested
an unprecedented 8 billion dollars to
help
tribal communities have the tests and
resources they need
to combat the virus and it's important
to remember that as younger and
healthier people return to work
and as we massively increase testing
capacity
we will identify more cases and
asymptomatic individuals
in low-risk populations this should not
cause
undue alarm the total number of cases is
not the full metric of success
hospitalization capacity mortality rates
are far
more instructive metrics
as we do more tests you can have
automatically more cases
we are relentlessly focused on
protecting the vulnerable while enabling
healthy americans to go back to work
we can do both as florida and arizona
and other states have
recently shown over the last eight weeks
hospitalizations have declined by
48 percent and they've just reached the
lowest point since march
it's a long time ago due to advances in
treatment
the fatality rate has fallen 85 percent
since april
our excess mortality has been
considerably lower than comparable
countries excess mortality compares
total deaths during a pandemic to what
we would be expected
in a normal year this is a critical
measurement because it includes
undetected giant virus deaths along with
deaths
resulting from lockdowns and lockdowns
can be very harmful
and we have too many states that are
locked down right now the governors are
nobody knows what the governors are
doing actually europe has experienced a
50 percent greater excess mortality rate
during the virus than the
us and their economic contraction has
been far
more severe under operation warp speed
my
is on track to deliver a safe and
effective vaccine in record time
we're doing very well with the vaccines
as most of you know
four vaccines are now in the final stage
of trials
the day the vaccine is approved by the
fda will begin distributing it
within 24 hours with hundreds of
millions of doses
to follow very quickly we're all set to
go we're
all ready and logistically we're we have
the military lined up and some
incredible people are just waiting to
have it over 100 million doses will be
available before the end of the year
we will defeat the virus and we will end
the pandemic
and next year will be one of the
greatest years in our history and we
think it's going to be a very exciting
period of time
with that i'd like to ask mike to say a
few words because you just left a task
force meeting
vice president mike pence
thank you mr president
this is a historic day and other than
the day
that i believe will come soon that
america
produces the first safe and effective
vaccine
what's announced today with the
distribution of 150 million
rapid point of care tests all across
america
it's a testament to your leadership mr
president testament
to this great team that you've assembled
from secretary azar
admiral jura and others it's a testament
to the partnership that we forge with
governors like governor reeves
all across america and it's a testament
to great companies like
abbott laboratories and the thousands of
employees who
mr president i know have literally
worked around the clock
since those early days in this pandemic
when you brought in the greatest
research companies in america
and said that we need medicines known as
therapeutics we need a vaccine for
america but you also challenge them
to develop a rapid point-of-care test
that could be distributed all across
america and enable us more effectively
slow the spread
flatten the curve protect the vulnerable
and save lives
mr president today's announcement is
really emblematic of the public-private
partnership that you forged
from the early days of this pandemic
as you said we met today with the
nation's governors the white house
coronavirus task force completed our
38th
conference call with america's governors
but all along the way from our very
first meeting you made it clear that
we'd spare no expense of the federal
government the full resource of the
federal government you made available
to put the health of america first but
you also
challenged us and you challenged
american industry to being the full
power and innovation
of the american economy to bear on this
moment
and whether it be ppe where we forged a
partnership to see to the delivery the
manufacturer of
hundreds of millions of personal
protective equipment
whether it be how we started with 15 000
ventilators in the strategic national
stockpile and today in partnership with
ge healthcare ford and general motors we
have over 150
000 ventilators in the strategic
national stockpile
whether it be the extraordinary progress
on therapeutics
remdessevere convalescent plasma that
are literally saving lives or whether it
be
you reflected mr president on our steady
progress toward achieving safe and
effective vaccine before the end of this
year
it's been that public-private
partnership that you've led
that's made these advances a possible
and on testing the american people
really deserve to know that when we
began as you said mr president it was
literally a standing start
we didn't have information on the coding
of the coronavirus until
mid-february but america's
cdc labs and public health labs did
their level best
by the end of february we'd done less
than 10 000 coronavirus tests but as
as you just announced a few moments ago
last week we cleared 100 million
tests all across the country it's
extraordinary we have the capacity to do
three million
tests a day it's a testament to american
innovation and the leadership
that you've provided also mr president
we've
delivered to nearly 14 000 nursing homes
in america point-of-care tests already
that are making it possible for us to
really keep focus
on the most vulnerable as you know only
eight percent
of those who have contracted the
coronavirus uh are in nursing homes but
40 percent
of those that have lost their life have
been in nursing homes and so we've
surged those resources and surged them
to vulnerable
populations but with the announcement
today this abbott laboratories buy next
now test
we began a process first announcing 50
million tests
to go to our vulnerable communities to
go to minority communities to
indian health services but as we told
all the nation's governors today
we begin the process this week of
distributing 100 million tests
to each state and territory in the
country free of charge
so they can begin to deploy those tests
on the priorities that the state has set
but mr president given the extraordinary
capacity that we have in testing today
we
we expressed a hope to all the governors
today that they would particularly use
these abbott binax tests to
open up america's schools and to keep
them open
and we heard about the enthusiasm of of
governors
from both sides of the aisle about what
this test will mean in
in helping to process helping to process
uh
the testing that will get our kids into
school and keep our kids
in school mr president let me just close
by saying this is a
we've passed through a challenging time
in the life of this nation in 2020 in
our hearts
i know your heart is with all the
families that have suffered loss
but as you said cases are declining
hospitalizations have been declining
declining dramatically particularly in
the sun belt
in louisiana where not long ago 50
parishes had
more than 10 positivity rate now only
three parishes
are testing positive over 10 arizona was
testing 20 percent positivity rate now
now it's less than four percent
consistently
but with cases and positivity rising in
ten states
in the midwest and the near west
and with this historic advance in
testing that's being distributed
150 strong around the country mr
president the american people
should anticipate that that cases will
rise in the days ahead
but as we as we more readily identify
those who've contracted
the coronavirus the american people can
be confident because of this
extraordinary and historic
public and private partnership that
you've forged because of this
whole of government approach we're ready
as we prove through the outbreak in the
sun belt this summer
we'll make sure that any community any
state that's impacted with rising cases
any school
that's impacted we'll have the ppe we'll
have the supplies we'll have the
medicines
and as you said mr president we will
continue
uh at your direction our relentless
drive
toward achieving the first safe and
effective vaccine so we can achieve the
day
that we once and for all uh put this
coronavirus in the past
so mr president with thanks to our
industry partners thanks to this team
but thanks to you for your strong
leadership uh i hope for that day and
the american people can be confident
we will not rest we will not relent
until we put this coronavirus in the
past
thank you very much mike uh scott atlas
would you say
a few words please as to how we're doing
and where you see us going
please
okay thank you mr president and uh i
also want to echo the congratulations to
the team
uh the task force admiral gerwar in
particular who's worked very hard on the
testing this is a remarkable day because
we have
state of the art testing this is not the
typical point of care test even this is
new
this is does not require any kind of
machine
it's very rapid and this is not one of
those
deep swab things that people are uh
reluctant to use so i think we're
we're really making an advance here to
do what testing is supposed to do
and that's to save lives uh as the vice
president mentioned we know that there
are areas of the country that have more
cases this is to be expected with more
social mingling and the testing
but particularly protecting the
vulnerable is the key here
we have not seen hospital overcrowding
we're doubling down now with testing to
protect
vulnerable people not just inside
nursing homes but in
residential settings and senior day care
centers
this is a remarkable advance and i
anticipate that as as this
uh virus uh as we get toward the end of
this pandemic
uh and the vaccine is being developed as
quickly as it has been
uh america will uh be uh
in a different position and there really
should be as i've said many times
the fear is not the issue here uh we
really have a handle on what's going on
we know what to anticipate and there's
remarkable advances being made as we see
today
thank you very much well thank you very
much tremendous progress is being made
and
i say it i'll say it all the time we're
rounding the corner
and very importantly vaccines are coming
but we're rounding the corner regardless
but vaccines are coming and they're
coming fast we have four great companies
already and
it's going to be added to very rapidly
uh they're
in final stages of testing and from what
we're hearing the
results are going to be very
extraordinary so
thank you very much i appreciate it and
thank you very much great job by abbott
right from the beginning great job by
abbott
thank you thank you very much
more
everybody
[Applause]
yeah i got you guys
i got you guys fine
yes i hear you guys hi can you hear me
i'm
so i'm going to wrap this and then maybe
let neil do with you to get the taxes
uh hey neil well president trump just
announced a big
expansion of virus testing in this
country
150 million uh rapid point of care tests
from abbott and i want to break this
down a little bit further for you
because the biggest headline here
is that 100 million of these tests are
going to be
sent straight to governor who's very
then going to distribute
through schools and the president says
that
this is going to allow every teacher who
wants to test
k-12 to get one uh and then there's also
going to be an additional
50 million tests going out for more
vulnerable populations
nursing homes assistant living
communities and
hcc use as well now at one point during
this event
um ago the governor of mississippi got
up and he called this announcement today
a game-changer he says that what this
means for teachers in his state
is that testing will be available from
patreon teachers every single day
going forward uh this event though
you know rebuild as an update on the
country's floor virus
testing before this event even started
though no surprise here you had
the dnc coming out and putting out a
statement saying that it's going to be
hard to give an update given the fact
that they say there is no
national strategy here but the person
who has really been in charge of the
country's testing admiral
he got up and demonstrated how these
rapid point of care tests how easy they
are to complete when the vice president
got up
and said that uh you know he believed
that aside from the day that they really
didn't know if he didn't have
a vaccine finally one of the biggest
days
be very noticeable that uh on a day as
big as this
is saying that this is the biggest days
before the white house
in its fight to begin this pandemic it
should be notable
that some significant members of the
white house task force
were not here there was no doctor fauci
no dr
burks the head of the cdc was not here
nor was the head
of the fda
you know it kind of depends on who you
talk to i will say though there was
a report an nbc news reporter was
overheard dr redfield the head of the
cdc
uh making a phone call on a public
wife overheard him saying that
everything
that dr atlas says is wrong
that's according to this nbc news report
uh
the cdc was back on it a bit saying that
that reporter had no way of knowing
who exactly dr redfield was talking
about on the other line but he
also of the cdc then went on to uh kind
of go
point by point and explain why dr
redfield
disagrees uh with dr atlas on a variety
of points from the efficacy of masks
uh to uh the potential benefits of
herd immunity things of that nature so
uh there's definitely some tension
between the two
dr scott atlas vote today congratulated
the president
but the head of cdc's after redfield is
not here
oh yeah
oh
but then
later
[Music]
[Music]
right
is this good
[Laughter]
[Music]
great
[Music]
come back
[Music]
oh
something's wrong there we go
i'm bad are are that
[Music]
yes
did you do that
[Music]
abc's
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for interrupting your day to
day
[Music]
um
oh
all right
[Music]
okay
uh
okay
[Music]
and you're not able to keep
and that's my job
[Music]
you are my first priority
and if bothering you
it bothers me and i can't do anything
about it if you don't tell me
so plug my email okay
write my email because if you sign my
email
that means i'm going to sign somebody up
that you know it's not a real problem
without resolution and
[Music]
i
foreign
outside
probably have about three to five
[Music]
minutes
um
makeup
wow
thank you
thank you
oh
all right
yes
all right
um
like
oh
you do whatever you want really good
maybe he's getting the perfect angle
right here
[Music]
right
okay she's on her way out